what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video I want to talk about how
Marvel could roll atom brashear or blue
Marvel over into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so a lot of you guys have been
asking me about this really before I
even referenced it and in the previous
video that we did and originally I was
gonna throw this up on Saturday but I
really want to talk about it so so blue
Marvel is is a really cool character
like like Adam Brashear is one of the
coolest characters out there if you guys
thought Black Panther was cool he's got
nothing on Adam Brashear Adam Bashir is
is wildly interesting because one he's
like a super genius and two he's really
really powerful now we're Viet were like
previous videos that we've done like the
living tribunal where that focus on
things like explaining the nature of
energy and stuff like that in Marvel
Comics what this one is gonna do is this
is gonna focus more on like in universe
history in Marvel Comics which I think
people like more nothing people dig that
kind of stuff more like how did
Wolverine become Wolverine what was he
doing over the top like over the course
of his life like that kind of in
universe history not really publishing
history but still and so so blue Marvel
was a guy who was made by by Kevin
Griffo right like Kevin Goro is this guy
he went to Howard University do this
guy's a genius man like if you go when
you look up Kevin Griffo the guy's got
like all these degrees in science and
stuff like that like like what does a
like biochemistry and like molecular
biology and things like that
the Duke could clone people if he wanted
to it's crazy how smart like Kevin Goro
is but he's one of those guys were you
know him if you saw him but you may not
recognize the name Hirohito he like
spearheaded the whole underworld movie
series and different things like that
but he create a blue Marvel and blue
Marvel is basically a character who was
intrinsically tied into the civil rights
movement back in the day and then in
turn his head kind of like vanished for
a number of years what Marvel does from
time to time those are guys who were new
here what Marvel will do is they'll
offer something called a retcon
retroactive continuity and what it means
is Marvel will say here is how things
have been for the last 30 years in
publishing history but we're gonna
change that now with this one thing with
Kevin Gerber I'm sorry with blue Marvel
it was the same way and we'll talk about
we'll talk about why here in a second
but he is a guy who in a lot of ways
there's like one of the many allegories
of Superman that Marvel has people get
mad when you say that but it's because
it's true like like Hyperion is the
closest thing Marvel has to Superman but
like this century Robert Reynolds blue
Marvel
and there's a handful of others who are
basically Marvel Superman because they
don't really have anything outside of
what Superman has right like how they
have their powers or might be a little
bit different but at the end of the day
their powers are still the same they
were cape they wear boots they have the
belt deal utility belt or you know what
passes for the utility belt they kind of
wear underwear or something akin to
underwear on the outside they're
basically pasty she's of Superman um but
when it comes when it came to the whole
the whole idea of Adam Brashear he
actually originated in his own solo
series there are really a miniseries
called Adam the legend of blue Marvel
and this the coolest thing in the world
so this basically picks up in the
aftermath of like Civil War right like
like civil war ends and like like you
know Iron Man and Reed Richards and all
those guys basically Captain America
loses superhuman Registration goes
through and you've got like Carol
Danvers Mighty Avengers and you have
like the actual main Avengers themselves
in Iron Man still director of shield and
so what happens is it like out of
nowhere this guy anti man just shows up
and crushes like The Avengers and Mighty
Avengers just like readily decimates
them and it's insane like and we're
talking about some power houses here I
mean you have like ant-man and you have
like a man Hank Pym and man Hank Pym in
Marvel Comics as much as I love Michael
Douglas and as cool as is you know Paul
Rudd is and Scott Lang in the MCU Hank
Pym is pretty much useless he can grow
like really tall he can shrink really
small and backhand his wife and that's
it like this is the only thing the only
things he and suffer from an identity
crisis and go through like five
different names for his character uh
he's kind of a useless guy but then
you've also got like Black Widow who
really can't do a whole lot either I
mean you know she can punch and shoot
stuff and get killed by Captain America
in secret Empire but so but but then you
have like she-hulk and you have like the
century Robert Reynolds and you've got
Ares the God of War and you've got like
these insane powerhouses and like like
anti man just like steamrolls them all
he's just like he's like I've only got
minutes left he's like screaming about
he only has a couple minutes left or a
moment's or whatever it is and like as
soon as he appears like he's gone he's
just he vanished and like Robert
Reynolds accenture he's just like I've
never fought anyone that powerful and I
fought World War Hawk so like like I
fought some pretty damn powerful guys
and it's just like yeah I guess I'm
saying although maybe this took place
before World War Hawk and
that I think about I came to a rough top
my head uh but anyway so after that iron
man's like okay we have to figure out
who this guy yes because aunty man had
reference blue Marvel and it's lately
he's like okay we'll start with blue
Marvel like we have no idea who this guy
yes now keep in mind Iron Man's director
of shield at this point so Iron Man's
like okay well use my shield resources
and we'll try to figure out what's going
on everywhere he looks he ends up with
like a brick wall like like the the head
of the worlds in like the world's
highest ranking intelligence agency
shield taps into the NSA the FBI the CIA
these unidentified intelligence
organizations I mean it's happened like
every single intelligence group out
there and every time he looks at blue
marble he gets nothing like it's like he
doesn't exist or is classified above
top-secret and so it's just kind of like
like damn like who the hell is this guy
and so like like Tony Stark's one of the
same thing he's like who the hell is
blue Marvel like what's going on here
alright and so what you end up doing is
you transition and you get this kind of
flashback right while you get this this
point where you jump back to 1962
alright we're in the midst of the civil
rights movement in the United States so
blue Marvel's facing off against against
anti man and blue Marvel unsuccessfully
defeats it now as you're watching the
fight between them like Kevin Griffo
writes it in by virtue of the press kind
of explaining what's going on that
basically blew Marvel's the good guy
right like he was a superhero before the
Fantastic Four before the x-men before
the Avengers before iron man all that
stuff he was the first superhero in
Marvel Comics he predates Robert
Reynolds as far as I'm aware because of
how the stories written and so like he's
facing off against you know if he's off
against anti man but blue Marvel save
the world countless time so everyone's
like yeah I blue Marvel you got this you
know that kind of a thing cheering him
on defeats anti man but in the battle
his suit was damaged and when he
basically like when he's like okay fine
we're done he gets up out of the rubble
it's revealed that he's a black guy and
like people start to freak out and so
it's just like like what in the hell and
then from there what you do is you
basically you pick up with President
John F Kennedy
asking him to step down so it's like
damn like they they haven't stepped down
because he's a black guy like what the
hell and so like then you pick back up
in the modern day and so Tony Stark's
going around and trying to find like all
these people right he hits up dum-dum
Dugan who was you know who has the
infinity infinity serum so he's
basically basically immortal so long as
he consumes it and he's like hey looked
like like we were all monitoring like
blue like we were Aki
we never had a reason to question I'm
like Nick Fury myself like all of us the
Howling Commandos the CIA the FBI like
like we knew of him but we never had a
reason to I questioned him because he
was saving the earth so like we weren't
gonna we weren't gonna you know scoff at
that if you're looking for him you
should stop like you should stop looking
for blue Marvel because the further down
this rabbit hole you go Tony Stark the
more eyes you're gonna draw and you're
gonna start drawing the attention of
people that you do not want to have like
you do not want their attention because
you're director of shield sure but the
buck doesn't stop at you the buck
doesn't even stop at the president of
the United States there are people out
there who are pulling the strings and
you'll never know their names and you'll
never see their faces but they can bring
everything you know and love crashing
down and it's like damn like dude this
is bonkers man and so like Tony Stark
ignores here and he's like whatever so
he starts going on the hunt
eventually he discovers um who I think
if I remember correctly I think was one
of the presidents Joint Chiefs of Staff
one of the one of Kennedy's Joint Chiefs
at the time the blue marble was asked to
step down and this guy was racist as
hell and so like like Tony Stark's like
okay give me the whole explanation here
so this guy goes through like the whole
expose right it goes to like the whole
explanation come to find out on the
backend the federal government was
terrified of blue moment like they were
horrified of him when they realized that
he was a black guy and the reason why
was because like at that time in a civil
rights movement the United States was
probably as close as it had ever been up
until right now anyway it was as close
as it had ever been to a second civil
war that was gonna be like the lines are
gonna be drawn based on race so it was
gonna be like minorities versus
majorities and that that like that would
have been any minorities versus white
folks the response to the federal
government was we have to find a way to
like get rid of blue Marvel we can't
kill him because everybody knows he's a
black guy now and if we kill him that
it'll look like the federal government's
cracking down on African Americans who
are doing anything to try to rise to
power
so like will literally doom ourselves if
we do that but we can't let him stay a
super hero because if he does maybe
he'll ally himself with the black
community and if that happens like what
are we gonna do to stop them if you
decides to take out the president or
take out Congress or the Supreme Court
or all of the above like they're like
our armed weapons won't work against him
tanks missiles the whole nine yards shy
of nuking the country and that might not
even succeed there's no real way to take
him out and so like at the end of the
day it came down to politics now some of
it was also super racist too like this
one general in question or whatever it
was he was like look if we're gonna have
a superhero that's gonna
the united states it ain't gonna be a
black guy and so like it was it was
stuff like that it was just like damn
that was crazy so ultimately Kennedy
asked asked Adam Bashir to step down
gave him the Presidential Medal of
Freedom and said you're not gonna want
for anything we'll make sure you're
taken care of
so Anna Brashear steps down and that's
why you never saw him when like Tony
Stark first became Iron Man and Bruce
Banner first became the Incredible Hulk
and all that kind of stuff from there
Iron Man deduces did that's how Project
wide-awake came into existence this is
this is a cool thing is this is Project
wide awake is one of my favorite things
in all of Marvel Comics okay so why in
the clock back to uncanny x-men 134 135
by Chris Claremont all right as a writer
Chris Claremont always focused on the
idea on the notion of like less build
the x-men mythos that was this whole
thing like we're not gonna do with Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby did and he's good
here's a team of people with powers like
it wasn't it's gonna be about that it
was gonna be like the world around the
x-men so you started getting things like
the friends of humanity and like the
right and all I kind of see sort of
getting like all these crazy
organizations project wide awake was one
of the earliest iterations and that
actually went all the way back to really
like uncanny x-men in the late 90s like
in the like 96 97 98 with like ball of
our troske even ball of our Trask
predated that actually goes back to
Stephen Lang but I think he involved
ball of our trust because Walmart Trask
was originally Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
or maybe was Roy Thomas and then like
Chris Claremont made Stephen Lang which
kicked off the Phoenix saga but the
whole thing behind us is that you ended
up having this sort of sense where
Bolivar Trask had a son named Larry and
Larry was a mutant and all of our trust
believed that mutants were a credible
threat and so what ball of our Trask had
done is he had gone to a guy named judge
Chalmers and so he was a federal judge
and said we need to create a commission
that will investigate mutant kind and
come to the conclusion
wink-wink nudge-nudge that mutants are a
credible threat to society and that's
exactly what happened just Chalmers or
you know order like this five-year study
this five-year study came back and it
said mutants are a credible threat
against society we have to find some way
to stem the mutant mutant population or
like contain and control it and so this
led directly into the formation of
project wide-awake and project
wide-awake was it was it was basically
you know kind of given by the president
but it was really pushed by Senator
Robert Kelley right I said Robert Kelley
was like okay like like mutants are
dangerous guys like because he was super
anti-mutant back in the day he's like
mutants are really dangerous guys uh the
present like Len he was
on his speaker polls as reelection
campaigns and so on and so forth saying
we have to deal with the mutant threat
and if the president's not going to do
it then I will
and because the president was running
for a second term the president
basically pushed through the Commission
for project wide-awake
which was which was headed by Henry
Peter Gyrich worked for the National
Security Council
Valerie Cooper um there was like another
judge Petri or something like that and
then you had raven dark home actually
mystique who was operating as part of
like a hidden hand in the government
keeping an eye on learning what it was
because she was leading her own
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants at the time
and that led into like from 134 to 135
that eventually led in to Days of Future
past
we're like when mystique realized what
was happening with project wide-awake
she was like well we have to show them
they can't threaten us like that so
we're gonna take out Robert of the
Senator Robert Kelley we're gonna take
out more McTaggart Charles Xavier and
that kicked off Days of Future past so
that's why that happened was it was it
was in a response to project wide-awake
it was a it was a 20 issue long theme
that led into that main story itself but
you had like a bunch of other people who
were involved but there were like all
these intelligence organizations the CIA
the NSA the FBI like state sheriff's
office unidentified intelligence
agencies the whole nine yards and it was
all about like monitoring and
controlling the mutant threat that's how
all that came into existence and that's
where the mutant Registration Act came
from so that was the original indication
for project wide-awake
what Grove Oh did with blue marvelous he
came back and he said because of blue
Marvel because of the fact that there
are heroes out there or various people
with superpowers out there who may not
necessarily ally themselves with the
federal government the federal
government wanted to launch project
wide-awake as a way to basically contain
and control those and monitor those who
were deemed a threat and then when
mutants began to rise to prominence then
the focus shift to them and so because
of that Tony Stark's just like this is
this is ridiculous like you have a guy
who was here to save the world and you
asked him to step down because he was a
black guy like you guys were so asked
backwards in the 1960s and so because of
that like Tony Stark leaves he's
disgusted and he's like we have to find
this guy like this guy or this guy
deserves an apology for how bad his
country screwed him over and so you end
up finding out that autumn Brashear has
a teaching job now and he's basically
married to this chick well then you
start getting into the past of this
check you start digging like like Tony
Stark and people started digging into
her past come to find out when the
federal government asked him to step
down they assigned her to monitor him to
like basically find him to be his
girlfriend and to report that
to the federal government on what Adam
Brashear was doing she eventually fell
in love with him and the two got married
but as soon as he found out what was
going on like as soon as Tony Stark
meets Adam Brashear says hey look like
this guy ante man is back he kicked all
of our asses we need your help because
like apparently you're the only one who
could stop them uh you end up having
like Adam Brashear who finds out that
his wife was basically a spy for like a
huge huge portion of their marriage and
never told him and he just leaves her
and then eventually she goes on and dies
she dies at the hands of an T man I
think what is this it's like it's like
dude this guy this guy got screwed over
it like every turn but eventually he
goes back to being her superhero and
then of course he faces off against anti
man ante man's defeated and that's the
end of that but like ante man like at
that point when the story was written
like like at that point when he showed
up in the present day his powers had
increased exponentially so Connor Sims
was almost godlike in terms of how
powerful he was I mean could he defeat
Galactus I don't know I don't know I
don't care but like you know like he was
he was really really powerful in terms
of all the abilities that he had but I
number series powers are basically
limitless they have the potential to be
complete well not really limitless but
they're like they're massive in scope
and the reason why is because he is
what's called a living antimatter
reactor so a marvel comic's here's what
you have
let's take like the main Marvel Universe
right where like you have the Incredible
Hulk and Reed Richards and the x-men and
so on and so forth that's the positive
matter universe then you have what's
called a negative zone which is just
like this whole other universe that
every other universe can access ah this
is nothing more than antimatter there's
kind of like this barrier in between
that you have to pass through you
actually have to reverse your polarity
when the Fantastic Four enter into the
negative zone they have to like reverse
the polarity of their physical bodies
otherwise they would disintegrate as
soon as they went in because you know
it's antimatter meeting positive matter
and so what is it of happening here is
Adam brashear encounter Sims were two
guys who were working together and the
goal was to create a kind of energy
reactor that would create infinite
energy in the world by tapping into that
sort of space between the positive and
antimatter universes and the reason why
is because it's self-replicating so long
as the antimatter universe exists and
the positive matter universe exists or
universes exists then that energy will
always be there it would take the death
of the universe really the death of the
multiverse in order for that energy to
run out and so because of that they're
like this is infinite energy forever
like we would solve the world's energy
crises the problem was that the Machine
eventually went went awry Adam Brashear
became like the perfect version where he
basically is an antimatter reactor I
mean
he draws on all the antimatter and the
negative zone and then counter Sims just
kind of dissipated and so Connor Sims is
like an unstable situation he's really
really really powerful what he can't
stay in the positive matter universe for
any real measure of time and so like his
powers are super super high-end and like
he's exceedingly strong and all you know
durable and all that kind of stuff but
you don't really see him that often most
recently you saw him in the Ultimates in
an all-new all-different Ultimates when
he became a Herald of Galactus and that
basically balanced him out and Galactus
fixed him for lack of a better word but
atom brashear is insane like he's super
smart he destroyed king hype like he
defeated King Hyperion if you guys don't
know who King Hyperion is he is he's a
he's a hero from a different universe
who killed all the cosmic entities and
all the earth superheroes and conquered
the universe like you that the guy was
insane
King Hyperion was wildly powerful a blue
Marvel successfully defeated him
but dude he's he would like he is
awesome because he's basically like
imagine if Superman let imagine like
Superman a black panther merged into one
character and that's a lot of what Adam
Brashear is but like he's super
intelligent like he has all these
abilities he actually operates under the
ocean it's kind of cool he has like a
base of operations under there he led
his own Mighty Avengers team the guy is
a powerhouse like he is an absolute
beast and I would love to see him in the
MCU because it would it would be insane
like I mean does not even a superhero
aspect I mean like Superman's powers are
a dime a dozen
hey everybody has those what what's
really cool about Anna Mercier is this
knowledge of like theoretical physics
and all that kind of stuff basically you
could take what he knows apply it to
space and then build out the space side
of the MCU by having blue Marvel lead
the charge it would be so cool like it
would be so awesome and I would I would
love like I'd love to see his character
cuz it would balance out like all the
intelligent people but still like I
think it'd be awesome I think it'd be a
pretty cool set of events to see but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section if you are new here to
come as explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob forth you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]